your man-made cannon this is first we
feast going down Waffle House be a part
of it it what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and Ellie
Lee and you're watching empty calories
you already know how it starts Jackson
Wilson clips this looks like a candy
chicken you could eat ha ha ha look at
that guy's the world's first rainbow
chocolate chicken so he's putting all
these melted chocolate colors into this
mold to make a chicken my subscribers
this guy have like over 7 million yep
sometimes I think that we're like a good
YouTube channel and we're out of the
right direction but basically like every
other YouTube channel people show the
red is done oranges Matt oh man he did
the throw oh my goodness that is amazing
it looks like it might actually work I
know we're going to crack on it but his
rainbow chicken does look kind of
beautiful making knives hot and then
cutting [ __ ] is like the hottest thing
on YouTube now everybody's doing it even
this guy and yeah totally worth it and
ladies and gentlemen join me in
congratulating lead to criminal chef
there are people who are probably
wondering you know you guys are a food
show you talk about food shows one of
the biggest food shows out is Hell's
Kitchen
where are the Gordon Ramsay highlight
have you noticed what I've noticed that
we have a much more polite yeah
compassionate sensitive Gordon Ramsay he
doesn't seem to be seeing red like he
used to big plus on the protein you see
dockings now skin is intact and it's
parsley
what would I do differently and not much
before I tuned in to see Gordon Ramsay
look at Bert's scallops right put that
chef in the crosshairs yeah and then
just empty the clip and I liked seeing a
borderline crime go down in the kitchen
on TV that's why I watched Hell's
Kitchen see I like nice Gordon Ramsay
he's our dad he found a card
you both look incredible yeah mg nurses
on a gynecology ward at a Macedonian
Hospital are fine for celebrating the
Christian New Year with cakes decorated
like vaginas looks pretty real yeah yeah
would you well no because what I do with
a cupcake first is you lift the middle
first
you always gotta just go straight
through the middle and then like the
middle of this is just like you know so
I don't know if you guys remember a rap
snacks I'm sure you do so rap snacks
words like this novelty snack that was
like big in like the mid to late 90s and
now migos has a dab of Ranch flavor
it's the dab of ranch jingle and boy is
it a sight to behold
damn what a devil right what is that why
would you make it happen
Oh kind of tired I know
kind of wish we can just throw the reins
and Nick Cannon and I haven't just
talked about it to your Russian or
something have you offered no yo what's
up y'all I'm Nick Cannon and I am here
to tell you why the Waffle House is the
most amazing place in the Milky Way the
first place I go to when I get to the
Waffle House is the jukebox because
you've got expect to move make sure you
put on some summer fling and fire the
Marvin Gaye little vanilla ice all of
that is in the jukebox you set the mood
then you get to your food it's being
cooked for you right there you get to
see it happy usually the less piece the
Cook has the better the meal is going to
be and my key dish at the Waffle House
right there on the corner of the menu
because the laminated menu to be
poor surfers stuff like that on it you
wipe it right off right there in the
corner t-bone steak and eggs cheese eggs
with the hashbrowns mixed together
t-bone steak a side of grits and a
waffle cooked extra crispy some people
like to go to all these other fancy
establishments I don't do that my
favorite place is the Waffle House
because the vibe is right the people at
air and food is amazing can I have some
fries with that took on a whole new
meaning at a Burger King in epping
customers are getting marijuana with
their side of fries
we're the drive-through when customers
News the code phrase fries extra crispy
first off saying that you want your
fries extra crispy that's like a
relatively common thing that people say
just on the code language I feel like
they were already kind of painting
themselves into a corner when customers
pulled out to the window they would ask
if nasty boy was working which was worse
his code name Derek Norris you have
chosen to name nasty boy why nasty boy
well when you look at them look at
Garrett Norris Norris and Gere born and
were arrested and charged here's another
thing to talk about too in the Internet
age is you have all these people who
commit relatively minor crimes you know
like this guy is just a small level weed
dealer but because the story is so
novelty in nature because it's just so
naturally funny it becomes this national
news story that even we're talking about
and you have Garrett Norris his picture
is nasty boy nickname and all of his
skeletons getting dragged out of the
closet as he goes through this wide
scale huge level of humiliation that'll
probably ruin his life
so Kukui say Garrett Norris is the
victim in the story I hope that Garrett
Norris gets the second chance that he
deserves
long live nasty boy that's a wrap for
empty calories check back with us again
Tuesday 11:00 a.m. yeah Sean oh my vegan
Camila Tisa come on every room
[Music]
I've even cooked in Waffle House um I
don't know I'm giving my pregnant in the
Waffle House
that's probably my next move